Puny code helper, colon, colon, email to UTF-8, right?
So it's like explicitly doing puny code.
Right.
De-encoding, I guess.
Decoding.
De-encoding, I just said.
De-encoding.
Decoding.
I promise English is my first language, guys.
Un-de-encoding.
Oh, my God.
Please stop, Saul.
No.
All right, y'all.
Hold up for just a sec, because we've all heard of living off the land as a red teamer technique,
right?
Well, unfortunately, I just got off a call with the ThreatLocker team, and they said that
isn't going to fly anymore thanks to the ring fencing feature.
Let me double click on that for you, okay?
Think of ring fencing as like an invisible fence around your applications.
As soon as an application interacts with some app or system resource that it normally doesn't,
bam, it gets blocked.
Even if that thing is native to the OS, like PowerShell.exe or certutil.exe.
So yeah, rip living off the land.
Back to the drawing board for the red team, I guess.
Anyway, if you want to see this in action, head over to threatlocker.com for a demo.
And when you do, ask for my guy, Andrew.
His demo was very to the point, and he had great answers to all my technical questions.
Check it out, y'all.
Seriously, don't sleep on ThreatLocker, especially not in this recent landscape of EDR.
Uncertainty.
Am I right?
Yeah, I'm right.
Okay, y'all know.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Yo, dude.
All right, check this out.
Check this out.
I got a good way to start this episode.
Okay.
Boom.
Space Raccoon Pillow.
You see this boy right here?
This is a Space Raccoon Pillow.
Is that wedding swag?
This is wedding swag.
That's crazy.
There was a competition.
Shout out to my boy, Thilo, who gave this to me.
There's a competition at Space Raccoon's Wedding.
For those of you that are listening to a podcast in audio, like a total psychopath, I am holding
up a pillow of Space Raccoon, one of my favorite hackers out there.
And at his wedding, there was a competition of like, you know, how well do you know Space
Raccoon or whatever?
Not Space Raccoon.
You know, his name's Eugene, right?
But I always call him Space Raccoon.
And there's like this whole thing.
And unfortunately, like our team didn't win it perfectly because it's like they also showed
like vacations that they'd been on and been like, what city is this?
I'm like, I don't know.
Like, dude, we were like geo guesser.
I know, dude.
Pros for like two weeks.
I got it.
I got to give a I got to give a shout out to one of the one of the people on my team,
because she perfectly she's like, that is the mountains in Italy.
And I'm like, that is not the mountains in Italy.
Like we were going Switzerland for going France.
Dude, we did.
And she was right.
I cannot make this up.
It's my bad.
Like literally, I cannot make this up.
Okay.
I use a I use a a Chrome extension.
Uh-huh.
It's called what is it called?
Moment Moment or something.
Did you tell people what what Chrome extensions you use, man?
I use a Chrome extension.
It's me in your browser.
It's called Momentum.
Okay.
It's like when you open a new tab, it like shows you the time and stuff.
The background picture is a lovely mountain range.
And at the bottom, it tells me where it's located.
Where is it?
Which is in Italy.
Oh, my gosh, dude.
Is this giving that up?
Dude, what was the name of that range?
I want to say.
No, it's not the Cologne.
That's France.
Oh, what is what is the mountain range in Italy that you're seeing?
Maybe it's the same one.
Let's see.
It's in Gieler.
Wow.
I do know how to pronounce this.
Yes, dude.
Yeah, exactly.
The Giesler Peaks.
Dude, okay.
What the heck?
That might have been it.
That's crazy.
It was definitely something that started with a G.
I can't remember right now, but that's coincidence.
Anyway, I just had to flex this swag on the people because there are very few people in
the world that have a space raccoon pillow.
And I literally went up to Thilo and the guys in the team that won this afterwards.
I was like, listen, guys, I need that.
You'll understand.
Like, I really need that.
Like, this is serious bragging rights for me in the security world.
And they're like, all right, sure, Justin, whatever.
Take it.
You know, like.
All right.
You need to put a shelf on your back wall.
Dude, I'm going to find somewhere to put it.
I kind of want to like put it right by this monitor here or something like that.
Yeah.
But yeah, shout out to my boy, Thilo.
I tried to bribe him with like $100.
I was like, now I'll give you $100 USD.
And he's like, dude, just take it.
Like, and I'm like, really?
Like, so.
All right.
That's awesome.
So what are we doing today?
We are discussing DEF CON research.
DEF CON.
Not blackhead.
Only DEF CON.
Yeah.
I mean, there is some blackhead in there.
Okay.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Security summer camp research episode.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And there was a lot, dude.
There was a ton.
I mean.
Yeah.
At this point, it's impossible to like keep up.
I feel like.
Yeah.
But we're going to do our best to help you guys.
Like maybe like five, 10 years ago, you go to DEF CON.
You can probably see like a lot of the talks.
Now it's so difficult to see like.
I mean, there's like three, four tracks, right?
Plus the village tracks.
Plus.
The villages were fire this year, man.
Yeah.
The Bug Bunny Village was awesome.
There's like a lot of really good stuff going on.
So we met a bunch of people at the Bug Bunny Village, which was really cool.
Shout out to the squad.
We met out there.
That was great.
Dude.
This is my first time, you know, in Vegas as a content creator.
And it's, it rocks, man.
People are always like constantly coming up to you.
Be like, hey, it's you.
And I'm like, yeah.
Who are you?
You know?
Like, I literally, I think I had a dream about that last night where somebody was like, yo,
techno geek.
I listened to the pod and I was like, hello.
Dude, it's, we need to refine our skills on that a little bit.
Like, I feel like I was not prepared going into Vegas for that.
And, and I, I, I need to like learn how to like carry the conversation and like, you know,
have that interaction.
I think it went fine in general, but, um, you know, if I had a weird interaction with you
guys, sorry about that.
Like I wasn't really expecting all that.
So, um, yeah, you get to watch a edited version of one hour of us being probably as normal
as possible.
Dude, I don't know, man.
We've been goofy as heck the past couple of weeks.
So yeah.
Yeah.
But, um, yeah.
Shout out to, to all y'all that made us feel very special and loved at DEF CON.
Really appreciate that.
That was great.
Very cool meeting everybody.
Uh, we gave out a bunch of stickers.
I think we need to print like five times as many next time.
We ordered like what?
150, 300 stickers or something like that.
I think two batches is 150.
Yeah.
We were like, ah, this is going to be plenty tons.
And in like five minutes, I had like 10 left.
Yeah.
They were gone fast and we had to start rationing them.
We're like, all right, we're going to take one pack per day per person.
You know, I had to take some for myself because I was like, I'm going to run out of these.
That's funny.
Yeah.
We get to the end and we're like, ah, my laptop doesn't have a CTBB sticker on it.
Like that's funny.
Um, yeah, we also gave out a bunch of swag.
We do have the swag store live, which is great.
Um, so we've got that over at ctbb.show slash swag.
So, um, check that out if you guys want, if you didn't get one at Vegas.
Um, and the critical thinkers of course, get a very steep discount on the swag.
So, um, if you're a critical thinker in the discord, then, uh, check out those, that discount
code that's in the exclusive content channel.
Um, and with that, Joel, I think we move into the content.
Um, we, I have selected, I have selected three, four, uh, write-ups that is pretty much going
to be all we have time for today.
And we actually may need to come back and do like another episode after all the videos air
and stuff like that, because, um, the ones that we, we chose for this, this episode,
essentially all the Portsweger team, um, and then orange, who we can't, uh, ignore, um,
Portsweger team and orange.
Yeah.
You know, they did really nice, uh, like text write-ups as well of their research, uh, which
I really appreciated.
Um, but I'm sure there's a lot of people that just did videos and, or just did the presentation
and didn't like do a text version as well.
So I definitely am looking forward to when everything comes out where we can go and watch
back some of the other research.
Yeah, absolutely.
I know a lot of stuff was live streamed.
So stuff might, certain things might already be live.
I haven't checked to see.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Live.
They did live stream this year.
Yeah.
I haven't checked to see how many talks are like split into their own videos and stuff
online yet.
Um, or how they're going to do all that.
But I think they're usually pretty quick with it.
So, uh, I would imagine.
What was that reaction?
I, I, I, I opened up the Defcon like YouTube channel and it goes super loud, like extremely
loud.
I think maybe your mic is down low.
So I've got you turned up.
And then, uh, I went to this page and it was like super loud.
Oh man, I'll turn myself up a little bit right now.
Sorry.
Sorry to our, our audio editor.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Sorry, Richard.
Um, okay.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
I mean, it seems like there are some videos up here, so that's interesting.
We'll have to go back and, uh, and try to view some of those, uh, in prep for next week.
But, um, it is heavy, man.
The prep is, is, is heavy for these Defcon episodes.
Um, uh, but yeah, I mean, it's like a full-time job, right?
Like I think in order to educate people on a topic like this, like, you know, either you
or them has to read through the entire thing, learn it, understand it, and then be able to
explain it.
So it's definitely, um, it's a lot of like content consumption to, to be able to like
understand the research.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Okay.
I'll, I'll start us off with this first one.
Of course, we're going to start off with, uh, the man, the myth, the legend, James Kettle
in his research this year.
Um, this was on, this is entitled, listen to the whispers web time.
Okay.
Well also, hold on.
Let me just go back for a sec.
I promise you we will get to the research, but the idea behind this episode is for us to
go through this research and take the pieces out that you need to know about, and you can
practically integrate into your hacking methodology and then talk about those.
So, um, I would also recommend that you go and read all these research pieces, papers and
stuff.
But if you're just listening to the podcast, the hope is that your hacker brain should be
primed so that when you see something that relates to this, you might think, okay, maybe
I need to go back and reread that research or something like that.
Or maybe you get some nice takeaways that you can just integrate into your methodology as
a freebie rather than having to go and read all this research.
So that's the, that's the, uh, that's the thought for this.
And with that, um, listen to the whispers, web timing attacks, uh, by, by James Kettle.
Um, this research I think was, was really interesting.
Um, I think my take on this is that it's not normal James quality in my opinion.
Like, I think, I think James normally has some stuff that is extremely like internet breaking
and, um, massive.
Right.
Uh, and, and I think this is very useful.
I think this is a useful tool.
And he even says this throughout the, the, um, the, the, the writeup.
He says, uh, you know, if you ignore timing, you're going to miss out, but if you focus too
much on it, then you also miss out.
So I think, I think this is less of a internet breaking technique like we've seen in past years.
Um, and more of, um, you, you just got to kind of know how to utilize these timing attacks in the way that he describes here so that you can exploit some really fringe situations in black box scenarios.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, I think, um, one really interesting thing about not just, I mean, this isn't exclusive
to James's research, but, um, you know, a lot of this sort of very specific, um, specifically
scoped research, like these timing attacks stuff that he's been working on for the last, however,
many years, um, is what you'll find is that the large organizations who end up being, you know,
at a certain point, super secure, that's probably where this is going to start to come into play.
And the ones who have secured almost every attack factor, except for these super weird, like niche,
like, right, like architecture specific, like, yeah, like that's where, and it's going to be super critical, right?
But it's that, that sort of research, like has to be like very targeted and fine point for it to come out.
And I think especially, you know, with the previous research that he's done, that's helped to secure
so many other attack vectors and so much of the stack as a whole that, um, you know, just naturally,
this is going to start to be like more specific and more like harder to exploit and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah. And, and I think he says in the writeup as well, like, um,
these things are everywhere, these, these timing attacks, but I think you're right in that
the only places where they really need to be exploited are in these really, really like
super fringe scenarios. Um, and that being said, there, there is some, some really cool techniques
that we'll talk about from, from this that I, I definitely think you should know about that,
um, are really amazing and applicable in a lot of ways. Um, but I, you know, the actual exploitation
of this at large, I think already requires there to be some sort of sketchy functionality.
And then you are taking that and building upon it and using timing attacks to like gain more
information about what's going on and that sort of thing. Um, so I think that's really cool. I just
want to clarify something I said, like, this is 100% James quality research. Like, like the research is
very thoroughly done, very well documented, um, very, uh, thorough technique. Like clearly this guy is a master
researcher, right? I just, I just, you know, the stuff that I'm used to seeing from him is like,
Oh shit, if I do not implement this right now, then, uh, I'm going to be missing out big time.
Right. And I think this is like we said, more of an exploitation technique. So, um, with that,
let me, let me kind of, uh, go into some of the stuff that he, he did here. That was pretty cool.
Um, one of the things that, uh, came out of this was dual packet sync as a, as a methodology to,
um, sort of be close to that single packet attack that and improve upon the, the single packet attack
that he's, he had been using before. And essentially what this new technique, uh, ensures is that the
HTTP server doesn't start processing the HTTP headers before it gets the body, because how single packet
attack normally works is you would just sync the last, you know, piece of it and, uh, in one packet,
and that would cause everything to get processed at once. But what he figured out was that some
servers were actually starting to process the HTTP headers before, even the, before they got the rest
of the, the last little, uh, data frame from the body and using this technique, um, he was able to
make it all sync together so that, um, everything, including the headers get, um, get processed at the
exact same time, which is pivotal for this sort of very, very granular type of timing attack that he
talks about in this paper, because it's like, I mean, he's in one of the scenarios, he was exploiting
like a point two. Okay. Microseconds. Yeah. You could call it nanoseconds, but I'm gonna, I'm gonna
say like 0.2 millisecond difference in some of the stuff. Like he was just very consistently seeing that
this one takes just tiny, tiny bit longer, um, which is just super bad-ass. Like, uh, and, and I totally
agree that, that like, I thought this level of timing attack was not possible, but after seeing the way
that he implements it in here with, with, you know, getting the server to process it exactly at the
right time, um, I think it's pretty, pretty well solved. I think, I think it's, I think, I think
he's got, he's made timing attacks practical with these tools. Yeah. I mean, it's really cool. I think,
this has made me think a bit about, like, the efficiency aspects that go, go into a lot of software,
especially for like large organizations. When you think about like, you know, Google, for example,
like think about how many requests per second Google has to process. And not only that, not just
process, but they have to be able to like run it through other software stack and like middleware
and routing and all this kind of stuff. And they need that to happen in like two milliseconds. Right.
And so there are certain engineering decisions that have to be made in order to make a piece of
software that can operate at that speed and doing stuff like parsing the headers, like as the packets
are coming in are, are like the decisions that lead to these kinds of vulnerabilities. Right. So I think
that could probably be a really interesting research point. If somebody wants to like go deep dive,
something like Envoy, for example, it's like a large scale, um, like edge routing software that's used
by a lot of organizations, I wouldn't be surprised if there is something similar there because
efficiency like is key when it comes to processing requests like this.
Yeah. Yeah. And I mean, at scale, if you can cut off just a little bit of time, you know, in server
load, it has a massive impact. Yeah.
Um, and, and some of those things will cause vulnerabilities inevitably. So, um, the other,
the other, so two more points here that I, that I wanted to hit, um, before we talk about some of the
other, like more practical vulnerability stuff that he, he, um, sort of coined new terms for,
um, one, he used a really cool technique in here that I think is a little bit odd, uh, because of the
way that it is, but, uh, I think it's a cool thing to know about nonetheless, which is he used, um, he was
trying to detect reverse proxies using these timing attacks. And, um, he was able to detect whether DNS
resolution, like blocking DNS resolution was occurring, um, by using a, a DNS record that
has an over long domain segment. Um, or what is the, um, what is the actual technical term? I
didn't write it down, but essentially, you know, uh, domain label, I believe. So like one of the,
one of the segments of the domain, right? If you make that, I want to say 65, maybe it's 60, yeah,
greater than 64. So if you make it 65 characters, then it won't even attempt resolution. It'll say,
Hey, that's not a valid domain. Like I'm not going to touch that. Right. So if you,
if you send one that has like 63 or 64, and then you see a certain response time and you see one
that says 65, and then it's a shorter response time, then you can say with pretty good certainty
that that domain or that DNS resolution is not occurring and, or that is occurring and that
isn't occurring afterwards. Right. So you can tell that differential and then use that to determine
whether you're dealing with something that's actually resolving that, that host and might be a reverse
proxy, uh, or is not resolving it. It's, it's such cool research because it's like invisible
fingerprinting where it's just like, you know, um, it's like the next level of error message,
like Googling error messages, you know, it's like, Oh, this responded in 60 milliseconds. It's Apache.
Like, yeah, dude, it is, it is really crazy. Um, you know, and, and I also, he uses a really
awesome technique as well. And I think this kind of goes into how, um, versatile you should really
be as a hacker and how, um, various areas of expertise can apply to hacking in a really good
way. He, he uses some statistical analysis on all of these to make sure that he removes any sort of,
uh, confounding variables that might be occurring with like, uh, spikes and server load and that
sort of thing, um, by just using the lower quartile of response times. And he found that that gives
him the best picture. Um, and that's not like some crazy statistical technique, right? Like, Oh,
I'm like charting it and then doing this and standard deviation or whatever, but it is like a pretty
useful piece. Um, and I think having that in my, in my brain in knowing like, okay, well, if I want to,
you know, reduce volatility in these timing attacks, I should use the bottom quartile of responses because
anything longer than that, something else is happening clearly in the, in the server, right?
Because that bottom quartile is going to represent the fastest that it's being processed. Um, and, and so,
yeah, just kind of having that in my head and knowing that, uh, I think is one of those great little,
like, boop takeaways from the paper of like, okay, if I am doing timing attacks,
that's how I should approach it. Yeah. I mean, it's such a weird thing when you think about just
that, like rank almost like seemingly randomly, right? Some requests will just like
go slower or not work because server load or whatever, right? Server load, like something else
is going on. Like, it's just like, it's very, you know, we like to think that computers are super,
super consistent, but, uh, no, they, they definitely aren't because there's like so many other external
factors that can affect stuff. Um, which makes this even just a little bit more impressive again,
because like the precision that was being done down to like the nanosecond on, um, some of these
attacks is just like crazy, crazy. It really is. Okay. So, um, the other thing that he had here was,
uh, he, he coined a new term, which is called scoped SSRF. Okay. And so this is a new variant of SSRF
SSRF sort of, uh, and this occurs essentially when you are only allowed to perform an SSRF to
hosts that are, uh, in a certain sub domain. So let's say, you know, I'm attacking Google, I can only
hit, you know, whatever.google.com. Right. And he coined this term in the, um, excuse me,
on the section of the paper where he was talking about how to discover these sort of reverse proxies,
right. Which is very similar to the research he did many, many years ago, um, on host header stuff
and finding crazy, crazy hosts that you can access via host headers. And he differentiated it, um, a
reverse proxy from the host scanning, which is the host is just when other hosts are using that same
server. Um, and he differentiated it and said, you know, this is sort of a different scenario with
reverse proxies because you've actually got a server that is a reverse proxy that is reaching out
to a different server on the internal network based off of the host header that you're providing.
And, um, one of the cool techniques that he, he did over this, this whole piece of research was
essentially building out a good way to identify these reverse proxies, uh, pretty consistently.
And, and that, that is the architectural decision that they're making using that sort of DNS trick
and some other timing stuff to identify these reverse proxies in the organization. And then hitting
those reverse proxies a little bit harder with like V host scanning or not really V host scanning,
but like host header scanning, right. Um, to see if you can pivot into different parts of the network.
Um, and I thought that was a really elegant solution. And I think that's something that I,
I could easily see like asset note or like some of those people that are doing very wide scanning
and really wanting under good understanding of network topology of their, of their targets,
um, implementing that in like a microservice or whatever, and just saying, okay, well,
XYZ organization has three reverse proxies. They're here, here, and here,
because now we've got a more actionable way of actually testing this. Um, yeah.
So that, that was a big one. I think that was a big one, a big takeaway from the research and
absolutely very cool. Yeah. Super cool. I, I didn't see whether or not he called it out,
but I am really curious, like what the root cause of that as like the scoped SSRF stuff
is in terms of like, because I know it mentions just sort of like misconfiguration of reverse proxy,
but, um, you know, from like an app six side, it's always nice to know, like, what can you actually
fix? Like how do you fix? Joel's brain is spinning like, huh, reverse, do I have a reverse proxy?
Anyway, um, yeah. So essentially what it is, is when the reverse proxy is configured to hit any,
like star dot whatever.com. Right. And then it's, it's, you know, you can pivot into the internal
network, um, and abuse that firewall or that, um, um, what is that, uh, DMZ, that DMZ position,
right. You know, uh, where that reverse proxy is on the internet and in the internal network and sort
of allows for internal pivoting. Um, but yeah. And then he does that, right. Of course, by that,
that, um, timing attack, plus that DNS resolution piece of like, okay, if I hit, if I see a very,
very significant statistical difference between the response of a 64, um, character domain label
and a 65, then it's a very good chance that there is some DNS resolution happening that is taking,
you know, a hundred milliseconds or whatever. And that's why we're seeing that difference.
Yeah. Yeah, totally. I mean, it's, it's really crazy. I mean, and again, it's just like, oh, it,
it took 60 milliseconds. It's Apache. Like, it's like, it's such like, uh,
it's like this invisible, like fingerprinting where like it, what's wrong with it? Like,
nothing's wrong with it. This is how it behaves. Right. Yeah. And he, he says that throughout the
paper, he's like, yeah, there's not really like a bunch of great defenses for this, you know,
cause it's just how stuff works. You know, start adding random, uh, response delays.
Sleep. Yeah. Sleep like three. It's like the anti-efficiency, like, just like, okay,
now we're going to add random amounts of delays. So they can't fingerprint what our,
Oh my gosh. So bad, dude. But those are the worst kind of things, right? Like,
there's literally no fix to this. Like, what are you going to do? You know? Yeah. Um, so,
okay. Last little piece. Um, I was talking with, uh, Franz and actually, I think
probably this episode will air before the one that, that, uh, we recorded with Franz. So,
um, you guys will hear more about this, I think next week. Um, if the ordering goes right, we'll see.
It depends on how long we run today. Um, but J Franz was recently talking about JSON injection with me.
And I thought that was really interesting because I don't really hear a lot about JSON injection.
And then James also mentioned, uh, JSON injection in this research. And it just starts getting you
thinking, right? Like two of the most respected hackers that I know of, right. Uh, are, are both
talking about this at the same time. And it's not something that I hear about a lot. That's probably
something that should, should trigger some, some thoughts. Right. Uh, so I don't really know what
that looks like yet. Um, Franz seemed to insist in that episode that there are scenarios where people are,
are essentially building JSON blobs with string con cat, and you're able to actually add other
attributes and stuff like that into that JSON blob. I have not seen that very often. Um, but he,
he insists that it's around. And then James is also mentioning something like this in, in his research.
Um, so I just wanted to put that out there for the people, you know, the curious, uh, critical
thinking listeners out there that will also poke and think and, you know, start identifying patterns
in their targets because, um, yeah, two, two big names are really interested in that right now.
So yeah, I mean, for sure. And just like, I'll say like injection in general, I feel is making a
comeback. Um, you know, people used to think of it as like SQL injection, but it's basically,
I mean, it's the same thing. It's just in all the other technologies, right? So, okay, you're building a
JSON object. Yep. JSON object injection, right? You're concatenating a string. You can escape that property
with like an ending quote and then start to add new properties in, um, um, GraphQL injection,
like again, like building queries with string concatenation, like string concatenation and just
inserting strings without sanitizing them or without having like a proper flow, right? Like
the traditional solution for SQL injection is prepared statements, which like pre-calculates a path.
So you have to figure out like, what is the, that, what is the, the, the prepared statement for JSON,
right? Like you build the object and then you specifically like go attribute over I attribute
or something, right? Like, you know, there, there are security ways to do it, but I think in a lot
of places people have gotten lax because there's not a traditional security risk associated with it.
And people go, I mean, what's wrong with concatenating a string and a JSON object,
like what's going to happen? Well, you know, maybe you're able to pass that into a function that then
interprets those as parameters and, you know, you're able to override parameters or add additional
options that weren't, you know, without, without, um, you know, talking too much about Franz's
research for next episode. Like that, that's exactly what he was talking about. Like being
able to inject in these sort of trusted JSON blobs and then be able to overwrite specific pieces,
specific attributes because of like deduplication of attributes and that sort of thing. Um, very
interesting stuff. Very interesting stuff. I I'll definitely be paying more attention to scenarios
where I think that could be occurring and, uh, we'll, we'll see where that goes over the next
couple of years. Um, all right. That's all I had for James's research. You have anything else on,
on that? I don't think so. I mean, hopefully, hopefully we did it justice. Um, I mean,
it's definitely worth giving it a read. So if you're unsure about anything that we
said or wanted some more clarification, go check out the, uh, the article on the Portsberger research page.
Yeah, absolutely. I know James listened. So James, I'm sorry if I messed something up,
man, like forgive me, but, uh, Oh, master of security research. Like, uh, but I think, uh,
I think it was good. All right. Where do you want to go next? Because we're pretty much hitting the,
let me just pause and also say like the Portsberger team crushed it, uh, this year with research. Um,
and, and really like, we're going to spend pretty much this whole time talking,
I should probably title this episode, like Portsberger research, you know,
brained up or something like that, because like, it's pretty much all Portsberger research. And then
we're going to talk a little bit about orange at the end. Um, yeah. I mean, I don't know how many
talks they submitted, but I know they had at least these three that got accepted. So very impressive.
I mean, it just goes to show that there's a lot of really awesome research going on over,
over at Portsberger, right? Yeah. Where do you want to go next? You want to do the,
the, uh, gotta, gotta cash them all or do you want to do the splitting the email, Adam?
Let's do the splitting the email. I don't know. That one's really cool.
All right. Cool. Um, you want to take that one or should I?
Um, well, let's, let's, let's take it together. So, um, this research was from Gareth, Gareth Hayes,
who we've talked about, inventor of Hackverter, um, inventor of Shazer, um, which I think just
released, you can now use your friends' browsers to like fuzz your JavaScript payloads or something.
I don't know. It's pretty cool. He tweeted something out about that. But, um, basically this,
this research all centers around, um, the email format RFC, which is what RFC 2822, I think,
is what it says. So basically it just talks about like, you know, RFCs are really interesting. And
I think probably at least once a year, there's, there's some sort of talk at either Defcon or Black
or Black Hat about an RFC that is, um, not being interpreted correctly or is being interpreted
too correctly. Um, or maybe it was written in a way such that there are pitfalls that nobody really
thinks about. Um, and so I think email address parsing is definitely, uh, probably one of the
bigger ones, right? Um, I mean, this has been talked about for a while. Um, I think, I want to say,
Z Shana was the one who really made that popular initially of putting excess excess payloads in,
and I saw him talk about it, but for me, the first interaction with this was, um,
in T in T's research on it back in the day. And then, um, you know, with, with ticket trick and a
bunch of other stuff like that. And then, um, I know, uh, Roshan also took it for a little while and
did some stuff with it. So there's been, there's been a lot of people that have poked at this, uh,
email RFC and Gareth comes in and like blows our minds with more of that. So something, something
says that there's probably more to be discovered in the, in the email research realm. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean, if, if nothing else, this, uh, I know that he had to update this article actually afterwards.
And he was like, Oh yeah, I had some extra, uh, some bonus material that I added to the end of this
that were like some more injection payloads that were like worked in more specific scenarios. And
like, yeah, I mean, it's, uh, it's really crazy research. So what is it? Um, so basically the,
a lot of it boils down to the fact that there are certain characters that you can, that are valid
in an email address, uh, especially in the like first part of the email address, um, before the
at symbol that end up either being transformed or interpreted or parsed in,
a way that allows you to do way more than just provide an email. So oftentimes, you know,
a lot of this was ending up as like SMTP injection, um, changing like the SMTP directives or commands
that were being put in like a raw email, like text or command or whatever that's getting sent to the
email server. Um, so yeah, I mean, it's really, really cool research. I think one of the, one of the
coolest things, um, was this whole like equals question mark encoding thing. Yeah. I freaking
loved that part encoded word or whatever. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. RFC 2047, another RFC. Very good.
Very good. It's called encoded word. Yeah. And it's like this encoding system that, um, allows you to
write, uh, encoded characters is like hex. And it's like, so foreign because if you look at
this screenshot, you're like, what, what the heck is this? Like I've never, this is a thing. Like,
what, what is this? What is this thing? And yeah, apparently it is a thing. You can like send hex
encoded characters, like an email address in like this raw format that like tells it, here's the
character set. Um, and here's like the data and then it ends up decoding it, uh, somewhere.
Yeah. I'm gonna actually gonna paste this, this image into the doc really quick and make a note for
Richie, uh, add this to the screen if possible. So for any of you, uh, watching on YouTube,
hopefully that will be up on the screen right now. Um, but essentially Joel, when I saw this,
I was super triggered because, uh, I did a Defcon talk back in 2022 with Sam Erb,
essentially an exploitation story of how we popped this enterprise software, but it had some crazy parts
to it. And one of the crazy parts was, um, this sort of encoding that you see right here, which starts
with like equals question mark. Uh, and then you provide like the encoding type and then you do
another question mark and then you just essentially start writing the text you want with equal sign
and then the hex value, equal sign, hex value, equal sign, hex value. Um, this also works in HTTP
headers, man. And so you can literally, yeah, hold on. Let me, let me, let me link you to this
presentation. I'm like, cause I, I saw this and I was like, I was in prep for this episode and I was super
triggered because I was like, Oh my gosh, why didn't I look deeper into this? And I sent a message
to Gareth and I was like, dude, have you seen this? And he's like, Whoa, I didn't like that can be done
in HTTP headers as well. Um, so there's definitely some cool applications for smuggling with this. Uh,
I just sent it to you on, on discord, but, um, this, this type of encoding with the equal sign and
the question mark. Oh my God. And cherry pie. Yeah, exactly. And cherry pie. Um, it is, is a, is a common way.
It seems for various internet systems, especially the stuff that was created way back in the day,
like original HTTP protocol and original SMTP to encode values that may not have a super clean, um,
UTFA or ASCII representation. Right. Um, and, and so he's using that again here to essentially get
these emails to have sort of malicious characters in them, which then get mis-parsed by either the
application layer or by more impactfully via the actual SMTP server that's sending all this stuff
out. Um, which is, is genius really. Dude, it's a, that's really, really interesting that
like that is specifically in the code. I actually went and I looked too, and it's still there. Yeah.
Uh, I don't know like when you made this slide, but yeah, sure. It looks, uh, it's, did they fix
something or no, there's, there's not, you know, cause I was going to say, yeah, cause it,
I think it's still, I hit up cherry cherry PY and cherry PY. I was like, no. And then Nginx was like,
that's cherry PY's problem. And then, and then they just, so it's one of those, you know,
mismatches again, where it's like, um, Nginx doesn't see it. It doesn't parse, uh, this sort of,
uh, what is it? I, ISO 88 59.
Yeah. They literally use decode header from email dot header. Yeah. Yeah. So, so that's not fixed in,
in cherry PY. And there was probably other, um, other HTTP servers that also support this ISO 88 59.1,
um, encoding type. And then there's also this sort of same sort of thing in, uh, emails apparently,
um, where a valid email can have like a bunch of question marks and a bunch of like hex encoding. And
then when the email actually gets sent, you know, it'll get sent to whatever the ASCII representation
of that is. So I'll just, I'll, I'll give our listeners the benefit of the doubt here that they
can maybe visualize this. Okay guys, listen, listen closely. So this, this email looks like
equal sign question mark, UTF eight question mark, Q question mark, and the ASCII representation in hex.
So for example, ABC would be 61, 62, 63. So it's equals 61 equals 62 equals 63 at whatever.com.
And then when the email actually gets sent, it gets sent to ABC at whatever.com. Um, and so it's,
it's really odd. Um, and I think this is the main, I think you successfully identified Joel,
like this is the main takeaway, right? Like from this whole thing. Cause if you look at all of the
exploits that he has in, in that, that writeup, all of them take advantage of encoded word. So a
really, a really easy probe that you can throw out there really quick is just have your email
in encoded word and send that in. And if you get the email, then okay, there might be something a
little bit easier to, to, you know, or this is an easy way for you to identify that this is something
you need to look at a little bit deeper. Right. And I think one of the big ways that he was able to
take advantage of this was around like auto invite stuff as well. Right. So like the, the,
this is basically, which is everywhere. Yeah. It's like in a encoding bypass for like email,
especially, which is then used in a lot of different places. So like, um,
say you've got a work slack and anybody who signs up for that slack with the company domain email
gets automatically added to the workspace. Well, you encode your email and encode
word and the front end goes, Oh no, this is a, this is a different domain. And then the email system
interprets it completely different and it ends up going and like registering it, your account to
a, you know, restricted domain that you might not have access to. And now you have access to,
you know, this company slack that you shouldn't have access to. Yeah.
And I think that this, I don't think slack was actually a specific example. I think GitHub
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to go ahead.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah